good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope everyone's
having a great day congratulations on
making it to the latter half of the week
that is no small feat do not do not
underestimate the fact that you did that
you [__] did that and you know
who did that best with the most Grace
and gorgeous red hair and shiny
porcelain skin it's my sister my turd My
Jacks
30 the compliments are just rolling in
today to what do I owe this pleasure do
you need a favor no wench I just am
feeling lighter than air I think the
spirit has left the building
and I'm feeling good I'm feeling good
that's so great to hear I love that for
you on this gorgeous Thursday as we
Usher in the weekend the long weekend
true oh I could use a long weekend this
is really exciting news and I wasn't
planning on doing anything I like you
know the the holiday kind of snuck up on
me I love to take advantage of a
three-day weekend but I decided this
morning that Ben and I are going to take
a trip to turdsville USA oh how exciting
I heard it's beautiful this time of year
I know it's kind of like this up and
coming Hot Spot travel destination and
I'm really excited that's so exciting
are you actually going anywhere no
hmm I know like the holiday just like
got away from me and to be honest like I
have such a busy week next week and I
feel like if I went away like I'd just
be tired
yeah that you need a vacation from your
vacation right so
um no I'm not doing anything presidents
it's just like it's not long enough
it's not enough oh maybe I should do
like a staycation
yeah because that's like a cool thing
about living in Florida like there are
so many hotels and resorts and fun
places for a vacation I'm gonna look
into it I really like need except it's a
vacation with a baby is just not a
vacation it's so true we were just
talking about that about a trip that we
want to take and I was like the thing is
if we bring Harry it won't be fun and if
we don't bring Harry it won't be fun so
like what am I supposed to do you can
leave Harry with me fly somewhere that's
you know New York is on the way drop him
and go you'll feel so good he'll he'll
be totally inside in my case it's not
about me worried about his care it's me
about me missing him like what am I
doing here without Harry you need to get
over that you need to get it yeah
Mommy and his Mommy needs him he needs
his auntie
also you would be going on the trip with
me when chalish
went to Lesh wenchalicious wench when
she Licious definition make the boys go
Loco that's so true we're constantly
making the boys go logo with the show
yes like actually we're making the
husbands go insane speaking of I had a
small update from yesterday the first is
I did get February 15th red roses uh
they arrived at approximately two
o'clock yesterday and it was it was
great I loved my daylight flowers and
the card said like February 15th is so
much better than February 14th like Ben
was trying to poke fun I appreciate the
effort but I'm just considering this
year a wash yeah and we'll try again
next year except you had a lovely dinner
and you went to a show yeah that's true
that's true because because I played
that yeah yeah yeah yeah but I mean
didn't we learn from things our husbands
do that in a way as that if you just if
you want something done right you just
gotta do it yourself we have yeah we
have to have no expectations and then
the second update was from yesterday's
episode when we texted Ben whether he
knew who Maverick was he did answer me
shortly after we wrapped and he said
you're boyfriend question mark which is
definitely like an over simplification
no no it's like an over
dramatic like we were we were in the
seventh grade we were like never not
once boyfriend or girlfriend like I just
like was obsessed
um so like I think if he like you know
knew I was referring to him as my
boyfriend he would be like that's weird
because we were never boyfriend and
girlfriend chill
but he got it right
that's so funny I thought it was an
oversimplification like you're the one
that got away oh you're awesome
for you it's an oversimplification yeah
for Maverick it's extremely dramatic
right he's like by the way that wench
from my seventh grade class totally
random and I don't know the word
dramatic just triggered me did you hear
that rumor that ABC is like looking to
maybe bring back Chris Harrison for The
Bachelor because it's like the
bachelor's like floundering I don't know
if that's rumors even remotely true but
I did see it somewhere no I haven't
heard anything of the sword isn't that
crazy that is crazy do you think that's
possible
I think
if Chris Harrison were to accept it like
I think that would be losery of him and
I think if the bachelor were to actually
offer it I think that would be illusory
of them yeah like in mudding
that they're big losers and that they
messed up no but like they fired him to
you know like as performative allyship
like cancel culture we didn't like what
you said we're firing you two years
later we're bringing you back that's
performative that's not real [__]
like you don't care you just did it
because people wanted you to yeah that's
why I don't think it's true
I don't think it's true either but like
it wasn't from like that unreliable of a
source where I started it seemed like a
decently respectable Outlet I don't
remember which one
do you think he would accept
I don't know I don't I'd have to know
how his podcast is doing like you can
make a lot of money in podcasting if
anyone gives a [__] so if people are
listening and he's like
making money he doesn't have to deal
with all that maybe he'd just be happy
with this more simple life yeah and
maybe it's like a sinking shield no but
also no but like he is the bachelor ship
you know like and that's why his podcast
like if it's not about the bachelor like
what does he have
opinions on I don't know that's why we
were saying when we were first reported
it like he needs to have a beat fishing
right deep sea fishing what farming
whatever he wants to go in on
um but I just would say like that would
be a situation for me where it's like
I have Scruples I have dignity you can
go [__] yourself
yeah I don't know if he's a scrupled
person but to be honest I think either
way like
the franchise even if Chris Harrison
were to come back I think the franchise
is at a point where it's like it's past
the point of no return like it's on its
way down and I don't know if you want to
be the captain of a sinking ship I think
anything could happen
Anything could happen anything could
happen it has so much like
recognizability there are all these
other dating shows that say they're the
new Bachelor it's like still the
standard yeah why can't we turn this to
ship around
yeah I guess but not with like the way
the current leadership you know but they
don't even know what they need to change
things and again it could be totally
untrue and this conversation could be
irrelevant but I thought it was worth
discussing here at the toast yes it
certainly wasn't going to be a story no
no
um but we are going to be talking about
Kelly Ripa which you know we've got some
not so mindless news today about Kelly
which is different it's new yeah we're
gonna be talking about her in a
meaningful way
which is something I'm just gonna have
to kind of rewire my brain for because
I'm not used to that yeah but she's
always at the center of like Morning
Show drama so that we're used to no it's
true actually either we're talking about
the most like moronic mindless thing
when it comes to Kelly or there's like
major news at her show yeah like she did
something like incredibly Savage
right I mean for me like I will always
you can add it to this list of my
favorite stories like I think that like
the way she acted with the whole Michael
Strahan thing like I never looked at her
the same yeah
like to me she was such an entitled
spoiled brat during that whole thing and
so not supportive of someone who should
have been her friend like and who
actually did a great job on her show
I really didn't like that I stand with
Michael Strahan and she's never even
offered to like give her a side of
things which because
there is no side to say other than like
I was being a brat
yeah by the way when she like didn't
show up for work after you know the
Michael Strahan thing for a few days she
came back and gave like a monologue of
what she said she was like you know she
basically said yeah I threw a tantrum
but I've been doing this for 20 years
and I felt like I was entitled to and
it's like okay take a seat maybe it's in
her book maybe she didn't talk about it
maybe yeah that's true but I feel like
there would have been like a million
press articles written about it because
people love to like take excerpts from
celebrity Memoirs and just like spoil
the most juicy parts and there wasn't no
not that I recall seeing but I
definitely was not like looking at her
looking for it yeah yeah so true
so that's what we'll get into today
that's what we will get into while I
plan my trip to turdsville USA I'm
really excited
um what's up with you not too much my
back is still out so that's weird don't
you think that's weird yeah it's like a
little sus don't you think
okay like who are we blaming you know I
don't know I don't know who or what to
blame and in the early days like when I
would sleep I would wake up feeling
better and now it's getting worse in my
sleep what the [__] that about
yeah no I mean I'm all I'm I'm all on
board to like hop onto a conspiracy
theory and blame someone but you got to
provide I don't have a theory I don't
have a theory yet
okay because it's suspicious for sure
it's super suspicious tomorrow will be
one week
that's weird
I think it's just Mama hood you know so
true so it's Harry's fault like you can
never fully recover from a broken back
because you have to keep bending down
yeah and getting this little slippery
seal
so I don't want to say it's Harry's
fault because absolutely nothing on the
planet will ever in perpetuity be
Harry's fault I want to say it's Zach's
fault for getting you pregnant
I love that love that one of my favorite
activities I would say maybe one of my
talents is finding a way to blame
literally anything on Ben yesterday
Theo before his we were both getting
ready for work and I was like damn I
haven't seen Theo in a while and I go
and he's like eating a whole bag of
Valentine's Day candy
chocolate I don't know the bag was gone
you look like the bag and the can like
now the bag the cellophane was there but
it was completely empty so there was not
a trace I was like sniffing it but it
smelled like Theo's breath I do not know
what it was
so I bought it
so it was a gift from Ben's mom she left
us like a little like cute little gift
bag with our doorman on Valentine's Day
which is like a bottle of champagne and
little chocolates it was so sweet it
sounds like you had like a pop in
Valentine's Day by the way
yeah I know it was kind of like that
like every box was checked for Valentine
except for Ben which is the only one
that matters
but like you built your own Valentine's
Day like you had champagne you had candy
you had deliveries you had concert you
had dinner like
so when the bad when the doorman brought
up the bag I did take it and leave it um
on top of this Amazon return that was on
the floor so like it was you know pretty
much my fault
um
but I was like so mad and like so
flustered and running late for work I
just like had to figure out a way for it
to be Ben's fault and I realized like
I'm so toxic
yeah but you can't be expected to think
of everything
no like what I have to plan Valentine's
Day and make sure Theo doesn't get into
the chocolate like I can't do everything
in this house so he had chocolate it was
chocolate I don't know I don't know but
he was fine so thank God damn go with
Theo big J big day for Theo yeah on the
one hand like it's always sad and scary
when these boys get into things that
they shouldn't have on the other hand
like I'm happy for them no as long as
it's not something toxic like I'll I'll
reprimand but I'm like you know what
good for you Harry threw his brother a
whole piece of chicken last night oh my
god did Bruno love it yeah but he ate it
so quickly I don't even think he tasted
it that's the thing with these dogs they
eat so fast because they're so afraid
we're going to yell at them that they
don't even take time to savor yeah just
like if I had known you were gonna have
a slice of chicken like I should have
put it in your bowl a little garnish
yeah warm it up totally
um so yeah Theo had probably a better
Valentine's Day than all of us combined
for sure
as he should as he should as he should
as he should because he's kind of like
asexual and he's like not interested in
Partnership
it's not that Theo's asexual I think he
has a really really hard time when it
comes to looking for a partner finding
someone who's on his intellectual level
yeah but I feel like he doesn't even try
it's he's a little jaded and like he
just thinks he's not out there but his
mentality is definitely why bother but I
think he could bother I think he could
find someone
well maybe you should talk to him about
it I will next time I see him I'll give
him a pep talk
a pep talk unless you decided you
decided to wear your bar sweater today
because there's been enough days I did
it was four days of holding out I put my
hair in like a low bun today so I just
figured
the bar no the low bun is a perfect
compliment to the bar right because you
don't want a lot of hair it's a big
sweater you got big hair you're just big
all around 100 but if I'm sleek and then
I'm like with my big sweater I'm just so
sleepy yeah they call them that like the
clean girl aesthetic like we're just so
like clean and cute are they still
saying that on the talk they they are
not as much as they used to but they are
we actually have a story today a
heartwarming Tick Tock story that warmed
my heart so yeah warmly that I need to
share with the class so you know what
let's dive in Jax I love that segue
without further Ado About The Love
interests of the dude's here are the
past five stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
State Farm the State Farm personal price
plan helps you create a plan that gives
you options so you get affordable price
and it comes with a lot of benefits like
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences we are
always stressing the importance of
personalization here at the toast
because you know there are very few
things in life that are more personal
than Insurance comedy poetry being a few
of them food but insurance is really
personal based on your needs and life is
just better when you can rock out
personalized
personalization means you have the power
to choose what you want to include and
what you want to leave out it just feels
better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that that's what's
the State Farm personal price plan is
all about you can choose to include
options like building your home and auto
policies which means you'll get the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you in the end you'll have a
policy that gives you what you want and
what feels better than that life is just
so much better when you can personalize
things to your taste and your needs and
leaning like for me like if I'm making a
Taylor Swift playlist like you know I'm
going to lean heavily on the Evermore
era and maybe just like a little light
on the Taylor Swift debut era because
personalization is key like a good
neighbor State Farm is there foreign
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary again call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan thank you State
Farm for supporting today's episode
today's episode is also brought to you
by Missouri
most people don't most people think
about buying jewelry for occasions only
Missouri does Fine Jewelry differently
by celebrating every day not just the
big moments their high quality pieces
are designed for you to wear your way
whatever your taste mood or budget
Missouri drops new limited edition
products every Monday they feature
responsibly sourced diamonds and
recycled 14 karat solid gold pieces that
you can sweat in shower in and sleep in
it's such a relief to like actually
invest in well-made jewelry that you
don't have to like take off every time
you start to perspire or when you want
to take a shower this is really jewelry
that you can live in it is made in a
really like responsible way and it's
just great to actually have pieces that
you can live with for many many years
you can discover fairly priced and
expertly handcrafted styles to wear and
love forever whatever your design
aesthetic is whether you're more of like
a dainty girl you like gold whatever
your style is Missouri has so many
different options for you when it comes
to jewelry that will stand the test of
time that you can have for many many
years that you can you know not be super
gentle with but it'll still look good
after a good amount of time and I just
love that there I have so many pieces
now that like I can shower with enough
to take all my rings off before the
shower before I go to bed because I
sweat my sleep it's not going to turn my
skin green Missouri is the place to be
if you're looking for a sign to buy
yourself the diamond or the gold hoop
the bracelet or the necklace then this
is it make your own day and go to
missouri.com that's
m-e-j-u-r-i.com missouri.com
thank you turd you're welcome our first
story some exciting news Rihanna and
family are on the cover of British Vogue
Rihanna Grace the cover with her partner
ASAP Rocky and their baby who they call
baby we don't know his name she's not
sharing his name but he is referred to
as baby she's talking about motherhood
Super Bowl new music baby clothes she
really you know it's a glowing
interview that she gave and she really
seems pretty open
um in terms of what she was willing to
talk about uh I just want to say like
kind of obsessed with the name baby for
a baby like it's kind of I know I know
the interviewer said like everyone on
this uh on her team and the parents like
everyone calls him baby so much that she
actually started to wonder if his name
is Baby
oh that's actually really funny and I
kind of like like that name it's like
only something around I could pull off
but like it's it's cool yeah it is cool
the pictures from the shoot are gorgeous
of course yeah I mean baby stole the
show he's
so cute he's so cute and I the photos
were gorgeous and what I've learned in
the last like week from just getting so
much Rihanna content is like I'm kind of
obsessed with ASAP Rocky like the way
he's like such a supportive partner in
the sense of like
he's like in the background of the
photos it's like not about him and I
think a lot of guys especially guys who
are in the spotlight themselves he's
like a very accomplished rapper would
maybe feel weird and like ego and it
just feels like he's so down to support
his girl and like I'm obsessed and
that's what Olivia Wilde was like trying
to say but like gave us all the ick but
she's right like it's every time I like
see something about him as it pertains
to her I like love him I agree I was
looking at pictures like in one of the
um write-ups about the interview and
it's all pictures of her throughout her
pregnancy and like she's obviously like
the star the bump they went to a lot of
events together and it's like crazy how
he was like always by her side when you
would expect like when Rihanna shows up
anywhere and especially like pregnant
with her belly out like it's gonna be
all about Rihanna but like they really I
feel like more than ever are just a
united front when no they're a family
they're a family and I think it's really
really sweet to see and also she talks
about how he's such a good dad and how
baby is obsessed with him and she was
like I gave birth to you like what are
you doing so disrespectful so
disrespectful but she feels as though
like sons and fathers like that's the
bond which is in a way is true because
she was like you know at the end of the
day the validation that they care about
is like from their father but little
boys and their mommies little boys and
their mommies oh and little boys in
their aunties of course so she didn't
mention any aunties for baby though
maybe she wants to just protect the
aunties you know privacy at this time
yeah and like one thing at a time like
we're debuting
as a family he'll have his aunties write
up in a later date she looked gorgeous
British Vogue I was also like such a
classy move something about British
Vogue is like so much more elevated than
American Vogue I think American Vogue at
least for me like feels very like
commercial now and like I don't know it
doesn't feel like a leech or like
exclusionary I can't explain it like
fashion is supposed to like make you
feel bad about yourself and like British
Vogue does yeah I think it's just the
difference between like Anna Wintour and
like what she chooses and I feel like a
lot of the time she's behind and So What
by the time something makes it to her
cover it's like oh this isn't this
doesn't feel fresh or new or Innovative
and Edward Anna full is just like on the
cusp I also think from like a personal
relationship standpoint so many
celebrities like love Edward and they're
like always spotted with him personally
and like privately and I feel like they
just fear Anna Wintour and they don't
like really like her on a personal level
or like they just want to remain in her
good grades yes like they're good with
her and everyone wants to be good with
her but I don't know that anyone would
say like I love of her like we have this
relationship like we we talk you know
she's my girl I agree with that I think
like Edward gets like so many dinner
party invitations he's overwhelmed I
think Anna does too but they're invited
for different reasons you always invite
people to a dinner party this person's
funny this person I like like this
person I don't want to piss off and it's
like a status thing yeah yeah so I think
like the the reputation over the last
few years of British Vogue I mean Nicola
Peltz and what's his name their wedding
exclusive was British folk like they
kind of just like get the best
exclusives especially for things that
like really should be like Rihanna did
the American Super Bowl they got married
in America in Palm Beach like for big
American moments I feel like British
folk is like kind of like always like
stealing the exclusive I wonder if Anna
Wintour hates Edward I feel like no I
wonder if like the Vogue offices are
we're quaking over this because this
should have been their story like it is
a lot about the Super Bowl and they're
trying to like they didn't like you know
over explain the Super Bowl but like it
was clear that it wasn't just for an
American audience no they had to give
context and like honestly the fact that
she did like the greatest American music
event of the year and gave the exclusive
to British Vogue is crazy but it's
really indicative of how American folk
is like not that like Fab anymore no no
and it's rare that we get a cover that
we're just like stunned by him or
shocked that that they even got it it's
always someone who's just you know like
they're met of Gala chair right here
someone who's like of the moment right
now in like a really Elite Circle that
like cool cool yeah but this was this
was a moment and she looked beautiful
the baby is so cute and like ASAP Rocky
like Thanksgiving it's like giving daddy
Vibes like I'm kind of obsessed yeah
really cute so she had some really great
quotes especially about motherhood
because she's just like all in on being
a mom also the interviewer at the time
didn't know that she was pregnant
um but she talked about like how her
life has changed the first roller
coaster month she said it's everything
you really don't remember life before
that's the craziest thing ever you
literally try to remember it and there
are photos of my life before but the
feeling the desires the things that you
enjoy everything you just don't identify
with it because you don't even allow
yourself mentally to get that far
because it doesn't matter which is like
so true I feel like everything
that used to be like a priority for me
is just like irrelevant now and that's
how I like it you know yeah
so um she also talks about you know the
baby clothes and that it's not cool
enough for these babies oh really yeah
and that she like kind of designs
clothes for Baby
um leading to you know maybe some sort
of like Fenty baby Fenty kids
um path in the future
um I like baby clothes I think they're
cute I just want to say I think they're
cute too and I feel like Kim tried to do
that like she had kids and was like this
sucks and they did like that kids Supply
thing and it's like the kids clothes
have been around for so long like it
works and they're pretty much disposable
because kids are always [__] and
vomiting in them yeah it's okay I don't
think you need to reinvent the wheel
like maybe a capsule collection sure
yeah but like I like like she was saying
how she puts like baby in kilts and like
how she wants you know just like more
avant-garde designs but like
I like the ease of a romper that's an
unrelatable that's a really not
relatable thing for her to say because
like the [__] yeah but it does seem like
she's very Hands-On so it's like it I
mean actually the ease of a kilt it does
sound pretty you just whip it open yeah
I don't know she might be trying to
start something should we start putting
Harry in kilts let me search a baby Kilt
yeah we'll get him like a mini bagpipe I
mean he could have red hair one day like
we just are kind of like stereotyping
him true but no but like he doesn't have
to have a bagpipe to have a kill like he
could just wear Kilt is it a kilt like
an Irish Karma yeah but it's also like
uh skirt
yeah I guess it it it's no it's it's all
yeah it's like a garment you know
it's like a shape of clothing it's like
skirt maybe maybe it's only a kilt if it
has plaid I'll Google it let's see the
definition I think it's it's a kilt if
it's a skirt that uh wraps around yeah a
kilt is a garment resembling a
wraparound knee length skirt made of 12
woven worsted Wool with heavy pleats and
the sides and back are traditionally our
Tartan pattern
heavily pleated
that's so Kilt
that's so cute these Kilts are cool
they're killed in it
LOL
um overall this was a win for everyone
like everyone came out looking Great
British Vogue Rihanna for us because we
got picks we got you know insight into
like what it's been like for her as a
mama and just you know new music of
course like the interviewer asked and
she said uh pretty much it like it's
impossible to tap her last album auntie
and every time she like you know finds a
song or whatever like it's just not
gonna be better so she's not gonna put
out something worse then but she really
does want to put out new music and she's
written in like recorded songs over the
years since Auntie but like now she
listens to them and she's like they're
just not good enough okay well we
appreciate a queen with a high bar and
not just like doing a money grab right
she said like she wants it to be this
year
I know but like now she's pregnant so
that might be tough yeah she got a lot
on her plate like
gorgeous so that was fun for everyone
yesterday and it's just it's just the
month of Rihanna I know I'm like loving
it I hope she doesn't go away you know
she's so private we get nothing from her
and like now we're going on two weeks of
just like endless Rihanna yeah I'm
overwhelmed
I know we're not used to it I know it's
exciting
are you ready for our next story
someone else who's overwhelming
sometimes Kelly Ripa will now be joined
by her husband Mark Consuelos
permanently as Ryan Seacrest is
departing Live with Kelly and formerly
Ryan Ryan Seacrest is saying goodbye to
Live with Kelly and Ryan and his
replacement is someone very familiar to
co-host Kelly Ripa on Thursday the
longtime broadcaster who joined the ABC
show in 2017 announced his exit from the
series with plans to move back to the
West Coast this spring ahead of the
American
Ryan has been doing this since 2017 now
yeah six years that Michael's Strahan
thing was six years ago
yeah that makes that feels right oh my
God it does not feel right to me that's
the Michael Strahan thing feels like a
long time ago it feels like Ryan joined
semi recently but you know time flies
plus there was like covid and and that
was just right suck right right in three
years but like it feels like I don't
know ability I guess I guess it's not
like suspicious that he's leaving like
doing it for six years is enough time I
don't feel suspicious about him leaving
I don't because I feel like since the
day he took the job it was unsustainable
it's not something that could go on
forever especially while he did his La
show he does American Idol he's so la
based like he's you know uh KISS FM like
yeah unless he was ever gonna leave that
this couldn't be his full-time thing and
if he wanted to be like the New York guy
um so I'm not sus I think he just kind
of probably burned out and had to
ultimately make a choice
he announced his exit from the series
with plans to move back to the West
Coast this spring ahead of the American
Idol live shows in LA
and his departure Seacrest will be
permanently replaced with actor Mark
Consuelos Kelly Ripa's husband the show
will officially be rebranded as Live
with Kelly and Mark he said Seacrest
said it was a tough tough decision but a
Bittersweet one he honored his bomb with
Kelly he said working alongside Kelly
over the past six years has been a dream
job in one of the highlights of my
career she's been an amazing partner
friend in Confidant and although we will
always be a part of each other's lives I
will miss our mornings together
okay I mean
I agree him leaving is not sus it was
never a sustainable thing for him he is
too much going on and actually I'm
relieved that he's taking something off
his plate like man needs to slow down
and take a nap remember when he had a
stroke like live on air yeah so I think
it's for the best now let's talk about
the replacement I want to say one thing
I'm so glad that he's leaving and a
replacement has been announced because
remember there was like months of Kelly
and Blake yes
right like everyone was a rotating thing
and Adam's none of us can do that again
yeah I'm glad that they made a choice I
love choices and a choice was made and
it was they already have a plan they're
not just like it's not Jeopardy that's
what I was just about to bring up so for
that I am grateful I agree but in terms
of selection what are your thoughts
nepo husband
yeah I just like
I don't know it's like an uninspired
Choice it felt like she wanted a a way
to have a guarantee that the next person
wouldn't leave and when it's your
husband they literally can't and I don't
think Mark Consuelos is like that much
going on outside of me Hiram Lodge is a
busy man but that show was ending oh
that's so true like I don't think he has
a ton going on so I don't think it's
gonna be a case like Ryan where he has
to choose between so many projects and
they're married so it's a good choice in
that sense because I'm sure she's over
the revolving door just as much as we
are and I'm sure they have good
chemistry I don't know something about
this just feels kind of lame yeah it
does feel kind of lame but I think it's
a good choice in the sense that like now
this is Kelly's show and now we will
stay Kelly show like yeah I don't see
unless he's a disaster I don't see him
ever being off the show and now like
they can do this forever but it's also
like I feel like for a lot of people
this live show was a stepping stone yeah
but for Kelly it isn't but I guess for
Regis it wasn't either it was his show
and maybe Kelly like loves doing this or
there's no other job that she'd rather
be doing except for the one that Michael
Strahan got
um and so now she's solidifying it like
this is my show I'm parking myself here
it's like the toast kind of you know now
there's like yeah
it's a job for Life yeah
I think like she's made it clear over
the last few years like this is not a
stepping stone for her but I think she
hated the idea of other people using it
as a stepping stone for them Michael
Strahan yes and I don't think she liked
it always being like Kelly and blank and
who's is it bigger is it smaller if it's
if it's bigger they overshadow her if
they're smaller they might get bigger
than her right and you know what this
like it's an industry of egos I don't
think it's unnatural to feel that way no
so I think like this is a really safe
selection in terms of keeping Kelly
happy and I feel like I just imagine
she's not like a super you know easy
person to like always keep happy yeah I
think on its face yes but I think the
idea of working with your husband every
day
um in a job in a job that you excel at
and is new for him like I think there's
going to be some fights behind the
scenes well he has co-hosted many times
so I think there's like a little bit
this reminds me of like you and Ben like
you and Benco sometimes it's fun could
you do this job with him every day no no
no no no no there's nobody I could do
this job with except for you oh turd I
set you up for that but it warms my
heart
bless you she sneezed on it's true so
it's so [__] true so [__] true
um
so yeah I think this is gonna put like I
think on the one hand it's gonna be good
for their marriage like they both now
have solid
working career pudding yeah um but on
the other hand like that's a lot of time
to spend with your partner yeah it's so
no it's true and I don't know from uh I
don't know what the audience thinks of
him you know
yeah I think they like him I think he's
likable I think he's just like her you
know like they just are I just think of
them in like their Instagram presence
and you know they're like goofy
relatable parents but also famous
um yeah they've been married a really
long time I think people have a lot of
respect for their relationship so I
think going into it
it's all good yeah we'll see
what if things get tense like I'm sure
no you know what if he like makes a bad
joke and like
and it's live yeah no totally
it's really tough to work that close
with with a partner it really is
especially like it's Kelly show it's not
like they're coming into this like as
equals sunny and Cher No that's so true
even sunny and Cher wasn't like an equal
it was like the share show yeah no
you're right like it's priest like the
dynamic is pre-established she's very
much like a guest
um
and ego is a very real thing in a job
like this so you're right yeah I wish um
all the luck in the world and I'm happy
for Kelly that like
you know the ship is afloat and it's
gonna stay like this for a while
I'm happy for Kelly that her Google
search results are now like a bit more
mindful at least for the time being no
and like this is real news yeah thank
you Kelly for all the work you do yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah something that you were sharing
with me yesterday Meghan markle's 2014
blog post about Kate Middleton's wedding
has resurfaced
a blog post allegedly from her now
shuttered lifestyle website the tig
reveals that Megan knew who the royal
family was and wasn't impressed with the
chatter around Princess Kate despite
previous protestations
so Megan quilly claimed during an
interview after engagement with Prince
Harry in 2017 that she didn't know much
about her Beyonce or his family before
she met him however in the blog post
from 2014 which was written when she was
an actress on suits she reportedly
revealed her feelings about princesses
and Royal weddings the now Duchess of
Sussex wrote that she was tired of
hearing the quote endless conversation
around the Royal nuptials of quote
Princess Kate to Prince William the
alleged blog written two years before
she met now husband Prince Harry
explains that she was unlike most little
girls who dream of being princesses and
instead was focused on Shira Princess of
Power
she's wrote quote for those of you
unfamiliar with the 80s cartoon
reference Shira is the twin sister of
He-Man and a sword wielding Royal Rebel
known for her strength we're definitely
not talking about Cinderella here Megan
then noted many adult women seem to hold
on to their childish dream of becoming a
princess quote grown women seem to
retain this childhood fantasy just look
at the Pomp and Circumstance surrounding
the royal wedding and endless
conversation about Princess Kate
okay this blog post just like
content-wise it has such pick me energy
like putting other women down because
like they like want a fairy tale like
okay rude
um so like just on its face like even if
she didn't you know end up being a
princess and a duchess like it's just
like I would read this and roll my eyes
like don't yuck other people's yums and
like put other women down because like
you are like you know I want to be the
She-Ra like cool we don't care
um so this is just like an article
written by someone I would hate like if
I just met them at the time yeah and
then the sheer fact that she did go on
to marry a prince is like obviously not
lost on like the irony of it all yeah
well so Daily Mail published this and I
think that they did it to like make her
look like a hypocrite like oh yeah if
you knew who the royal family was and
you said you didn't okay but like I
don't think she's I don't think this
makes her hypocrite I actually think
this is very in line with everything she
said like
she of course knew who the royal family
was first of all she's like an educated
woman she doesn't live under a rock like
but no maybe she didn't like follow them
and I do believe that but like she knew
who the royal family was and she knew
there was a royal wedding at one time
and she was right culture writer for her
blog and so she was commenting on the
culture like I don't think that that's
so crazy me neither um but I think it's
not like a gotcha moment I agreed in the
way that they think that it is and I do
think that like actually her stance on
like I roll at princess does kind of
explain why she's not impressed by you
know the role that she married into and
and
didn't like care or need for any of that
and instead like being a powerful woman
which is what you know now Shira is more
important to her so I actually think
like this is congruous
yes I agree it all tracks but it does
make me roll my eyes oh yeah I I don't
care to know about Shira brother of here
yeah no it's just like oh my God like
it's it's like
so leave everyone alone you know like I
would just if I was writing an article
on the same topic I would have literally
the opposite
thesis
um but I agree if anything I think it
instead of pointing out some sort of
hypocrisy I think it actually points to
like a a consistency in her world view
yeah and like a disdain for all of the
Pomp and Circumstance and royalty and
I'm sure as she got to know Harry she
probably came to like respect more of it
but like she's not a little girl who
dreamed of being a princess
right and it's like she's making that
her personality and putting down other
girls who did and that makes me roll my
eyes but I also like this blog post is
from 10 years ago yeah it's like
evaluating it as if she wrote it today
it's just like not fair agreed and it
goes against everything I believe in to
bring up some things people wrote many
many years ago
um and trying to fit it into the world
we live in now it's irrelevant and you
know what as
judge proceeding over this episode I'm
having this evidence thrown out I agree
and I do so right it did what they
thought it it does same
okay and when I first saw it I was like
oh my God I know but then you read it
and it's like there's nothing here and
it could be like so much worse like oh
my God actually talked crap
or she could have been like falling over
how beautiful was the Jazz
you know like agreed it could have been
so much worse so much Choice it's a
nothing burger no and you know what it
shows it shows she was scribbled then
and she's scribbled now no and
um
it's just a titillating headline like
that she had a blog post about the royal
wedding but like she really didn't she
had a blog post about
female power or whatever ahan Shira
Shira
uh before we continue let me just let
everyone know super important
announcement the rest of the episode is
brought to you by ear doctor clean air
is one of the fastest and easiest ways
we can have a positive impact on our
health improve the quality of our indoor
air with high quality air purifier all
you have to do is breathe with air
doctor I'm an air doctor right over
there she's always just purifying
wherever I walk by she's like oh girl is
here let me purify you've got to check
out air doctor because you're breathing
20 000 breaths per day and Air Doctor is
filtering out dangerous contaminants and
allergens so your lungs don't have to
air doctor uses an ultra HEPA filter
that's been independently tested to
remove 99.99 of tested bacteria and
virus allergens can vary in size but the
average pollen size is about 25 microns
and Air Doctor captures particles as
small as 0.003 microns in size so that's
100 times smaller than even the HEPA
standard
Americans are spending 90 of our time
indoors these days and according to the
EPA indoor air can be two to five times
more polluted than outdoor air so with
Air Doctor there's no need to worry
about the noise they use their exclusive
professional whisper Jets fans that are
30 quieter than the fans found in an
ordinary purifier and that means you can
run air doctor at the highest speeds
while still enjoying a peaceful home
environment there's nothing better than
buying something and like having it do
all the work for you like I have I got
the air doctor like over a year ago when
I tell you like I have left it alone
like it's just it's always working for
me I don't have to go in and do a
million things and there's such a
visible difference in the air here I
also have one at home I think it's so
good to use when you're sleeping if you
wake up with that dry throat or like bad
allergies maybe because the air in your
house is not great and with everyone
working from home and spending a lot of
time at home it's important
so air doctor comes with the no
questions asked 30-day money-back
guarantee so if you don't love it just
send it back for a refund minus the
shipping head to airdoctorpro.com use
promo code toast and depending on the
model you can receive up to 35 off
that's up to 35 off but only if you go
to Air
Doctor pro.com promo code toast
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
next story is some good news coming out
of tick tock
um
a Vermont man's book becomes a
bestseller 10 years after its release
thanks to his daughter's Tick Tock Lloyd
Devereaux Richards is now a best-selling
author more than a decade after
publishing his first novel a thriller
titled Stone maidens but the road to
publishing success was an arduous one
for the 74 year old father of three from
Vermont until his daughter hatched a
plan to get his book the attention she
felt it deserved Stone maidens was
published by Thomas and Mercer in
November 2012 about 14 years after Lloyd
began writing the book The Paper
reported the book was reportedly
inspired by a series of crimes that
occurred in the mid-1970s while he
attended law school at Indiana
University
unfortunately Stone maidens did not gain
much traction among readers when it was
initially released but his 40 year old
daughter wasn't about to give up on her
father's dream earlier this month
Marguerite Richards made the decision to
start a Tick-Tock account on her
father's behalf with the goal of
promoting his novel
she said it was such a great book and I
knew how important it was to him I
thought maybe it's just because nobody
knows about the book he was skeptical at
the time but it turns out that she was
right she created a tick tock with her
father's story
um saying you know how it was like
videos of him showing like how he worked
14 years um to write this book while
also working a full-time job and
providing for his kids he published it
and it didn't have that many sales or
anything like let's help him get where
he needs to go the tick tock has been
viewed more than 43 million times and
has received more than 9 million likes
and now it is like a number one best
seller on Amazon under Thrillers and
it's like number seven overall and this
man's a star
this is just you never every now and
then like social media really does its
thing and this actually happens quite a
lot on Tick Tock
um so this is like a formula the girl
was following because I've seen quite a
few you know this girl over covid she
was like my dad is like a English
teacher and he um is hosting like these
virtual poetry lessons like to teach
people how to write poetry and only one
person showed up like can we get more
people and then he had like a thousand
people like there's so many cute stories
like this or like you know my mom spent
her whole life wanting to open her own
restaurant now she has her own taco shop
and like it's opening day and nobody
came and there's a line around the
corner now like so it's this is a thing
that happens on Tick Tock that's so
sweet and it's you know things you know
parent kids doing things for their
parents and it's it's really beautiful
and it's like an emotional thing and
this is an amazing story an amazing
story and I've heard the book is pretty
good and then you can read it yeah no I
think we should pick it for the redheads
I was just looking at it on Goodreads
and now has it has 4.04 Stars 526
ratings so I guess not everyone who's
bought it so far is Reddit
um
but I'm there I kind of do want to read
it like I want to be a part of this good
news I know it's so it's so sweet
precious and it's so pure
it's so precious it's so pure and it
really shows how like the internet
really can be good if we didn't all just
like sit around fighting about like
pronouns like we could just like be good
yeah until they find his old tweets oh
you're so right until they find until
someone reads the book and finds a
problematic passage oh right right no
you're so right this guy like with
especially it was written 12 years ago
with the internet games
the internet giveth the internet taketh
away yeah that's like remember that
Budweiser that beer guy what did that
guy do
swimming in Idaho he was raising money
with beer
yes yeah yeah a lot of money for a good
cause but then he had old tweets what is
going on in your house oh you can hear
that some furniture is being moved
downstairs I'm really excited about it
but um it is really loud yeah my deepest
apologies okay but I'll post a picture
later so everyone can be excited about
what's happening so it'll be worth it
yeah yeah check my Ig at Jackie ashrae
um I wrote a book 14 years ago and it
didn't get the sales that I wanted
please
please go get it it's called girl with
no job yeah [__] rude growing the job
crazy beautiful life of an Instagram
third sponsor just kidding New York
Times bestseller
and
um also what reminds me of the internet
just not being able to accept something
good for what it is Mr Beast we never
did that as a story oh yeah but that was
[__] crazy yeah can you give me the
rundown on what the backlash was for him
okay I feel like you would know just as
well as me um because I just saw like
bits and pieces but so Mr Beast who's a
Creator who like does a lot of Goodwill
creating right like charity he's always
just giving away money too not like
Charities obviously Charities no charity
people people in need yes and he's like
the number one person on YouTube right
yeah he's huge huge and so he
found like he a thousand people who are
blind he paid for their surgeries to
cure blindness because it's like a
really expensive surgery but there's a
surgery that exists that can make the
blind see so we did that for a thousand
people and did a video and it was like
so beautiful but then there's backlash
saying that like the whole deed was
inherently ableist
yeah and so I just wanna for like kind
of make my last will and testament like
if I do ever go blind like I get me the
surgery okay you want to see again yeah
and maybe that makes me ableist but I
just can't with these words anymore I
really can't these labels like ableist
you want to know why because there are
things out there that really are
terribly ableist and terribly
transphobic and terribly racist and
terribly homophobic and terribly
anti-semitic and we're playing fast and
loose with these terms that they're
losing their meaning because like
because I feel like especially on the
internet people really try to have like
nuanced conversations
um and that never works out we just end
up throwing a label at them like well
you're homophobic and I don't think I
think more often than not that person
isn't the the word and we're we're using
these words too much that they've lost
all meaning and I think you know
I think we're doing ourselves a
disservice like I can't anymore with
just the way we just call everyone a
word because they they try to have like
a nuanced conversation and maybe what
they say is like a little out outside
the lines of what PC culture is but PC
culture has like the norm now is like
what used to be The Fringe the norm is
abnormal what right so it's like the
norm is now what used to be like The
Fringe of the culture so it's impossible
to have nuanced conversations without
just being labeled as something and it's
so toxic because we can't talk right and
I do think like privately people have
like real conversations with one another
but then it's like publicly like no one
wants to [__] go there because like
why do you want your license
so everyone just sort of like backs off
but then like the the most extreme
opinion becomes the norm ones that are
that are being heard becomes the norm
yeah
so I'm just like over it like I really
am bring back conversations yeah
um also like Mr Beast helping a thousand
disabled people like I just don't know
how then it's beautiful that's [__]
crazy like that's a [__] stretch
don't hurt your shoulder man no that's
the biggest stretch I've ever heard and
really I think upside down no I think
people who think that way and who are
constantly looking for for an angle to
make something good bad like I think
that's like an undiagnosed mental
illness I really do I think like the the
the constant hunting
um and people who are really chronically
spend their time online I think those
people are really not okay
yeah no I agree and more often than not
those people are like journalists or
people with like with real jobs it's not
like these Fringe people no they're
people with platforms or people are
respected right they're like Elites in
the country yeah
so I don't know what's going on but I'll
say once I'll say it again people are
not [__] okay and I want no part of
it agreed that's why we have to create
our own little Haven toast toast Haven
toast Haven like don't [__] come for
me that's not that is not something that
you can do here like I will block you
and I will delete everything you say
because you want to know why it's a free
country [__] you don't like it move
because I can
of country I learned something so
interesting about our girl Jacqueline
yesterday me oh yeah I'm like Jaclyn
Hill what did she do Jacqueline ostrich
has never been to Canada
I have never been to Canada I've never
visited our neighbors to the north watch
someone's gonna find an old picture of
me in Canada be like wow
um no I literally I don't believe I I
know I have a pretty good memory I think
I would know like if I ever took a trip
to Canada and I haven't and I just feel
like that's [__] weird is it what am
I missing there except like I'm the I've
seen some really beautiful things like
on the west coast of Canada which is
like really far yeah it is but it's
beautiful like I'm still trying to go to
Montana I've actually been to Montana so
that I remember but
um like you're missing on the on the
East Coast you're missing some really
flourishing thriving Jewish communities
in Toronto and Montreal Montreal is also
Brian says the Rome of the North
wow in what way history you know there's
cobblestone streets it's very French oh
it's very French up there right it's
also the Queen's domain it is so like I
guess I could go it's part of the
Commonwealth and be a part of the
Commonwealth you know nothing's ever
brought me to Canada no school trip no
bachelorette party no work opportunity
like the Canadians have never requested
your girl no they haven't but like I
have been so many times on a camp trip
for work many times I didn't go to that
camp that you went to I know just for
laughs didn't want to hear my jokes yeah
I did perform it just for laughs I feel
like I'm always going to like panels and
stuff at in Canada you're big in Canada
because it's so Jewish and actually I
think when you break down our
demographics Toronto is maybe top three
maybe two even of our biggest
demographics for the toast listenership
we're International baby well I mean I'm
open to going you know it's not like a
a Prejudice I have against the country
oh you're not xenophobic I'm not
cagnophobic so here's Nina but though
people will say that right but like not
going to Canada like I've been outside
the country so like you literally
they're gonna start something be like
Chucky today is ableist and xenophobic
Jackie that was the joke I made I'm like
oh you're not even a phobic and you're
like well I'm not Canada phobic I'm like
oh wait so you are xenophobic no no I
heard you but just like using that label
wasn't even like an apt just around
these words people will come from my
neck that's right that was me coming
full circle harking back to a
conversation we had five minutes no I
know it's funny until it's yeah Jackie I
know Jackie really well she's not
xenophobic and she's not Canada phobic
either no I'm not it's just like a
coincidence that I've never been
no it's crazy
crazy you're kind of like a crazy girl
well that we knew yeah it's so true so
true
I'm dreading going into the fifth and
final story because it's really sad oh
no yeah
what is a but um since I just told you
guys that I'll just get into it
the captain of the Thai soccer team that
was in the cave for two weeks back in
2018 has died from a head injury in the
UK at the age of 17. oh that's terrible
one of the 12 boys dramatically rescued
from a Thai cave in 2018 has died in the
UK Dom uh he goes by Dom but his name is
Dom pitch promptep was found unconscious
in his dorm in leicestershire England on
Sunday the BBC reported on Wednesday he
was taken to a hospital where he later
died various reports in Thailand say
that Dom who the BBC has said he
attended a Soccer Academy there since
late last year suffered a hand injury he
was the captain of the Thai boys soccer
team which was trapped inside a cave for
over two weeks in 2018 which we all
remember while exploring such a crazy
story such a crazy story I don't think I
remember them being stuck there for two
weeks yeah that's a crazy amount of time
it was so crazy uh he was the captain of
the that I got stuck there
um in a statement released to people the
leicestershire police confirm they are
not treating the boy's death as
suspicious
uh shortly before 1 pm on Sunday police
were called to the boarding school in
leicestershire Road the call concerned
the welfare of a pupil 17 year old boy
who was taken to the hospital he has
since died the boy's death is not being
treated as suspicious and a file will be
prepared for the coroner I don't know
how a 17 year old sudden death is not
treated as suspicious
well because he had an injury I had
injury from what
from the cave no no oh no I don't think
it has anything to do with the cave Oh I
thought that's what you said no sorry
he's just like one of the cave boys
that's how we know him oh and he died at
the age of 17 in his dorm for my head
injury and it's not being treated as
suspicious oh well that's and them not
treating it as suspicious is even more
suspicious yeah so a lot I thought he
like eventually came to his injury like
an injury sustained in the cave not that
I've seen in any of this and everyone
made it out alive and well alive not
injured not injured oh it was a miracle
then I'm wrong
um that's terrible really terrible um a
lot of his former teammates from the
cave put out statements
um
just expressing their sadness and the
Thai Community is very sad as well but
that was such a crazy time such a crazy
time for like a week we were all just
waiting that was so sad and it was like
one boy at a time and we're like yeah
yeah we got him and like elon's trying
to send a submarine but everyone said no
Elon your submarine will know that was
weird when Elon was like starting beef
with everyone starting to leave with
everyone he had like a submarine in a
swimming pool at a college trying to see
if he could get him out well that's the
kind of the footage now that's coming
out of turkey and Syria from the
earthquake which is so sad it's like
there's so many people under the rubble
and like every time they get one there's
like a whole celebration but like
there's so many more people that is so
sad so sad terrible what's going on in
the world you know yeah so I'm sorry to
end on that note I just um those boys
they were like Global Heroes Heroes and
the captain yeah that's terrible yeah
honestly rest in peace and I hope his
family
find some sort of comfort and may his
memory be a blessing amen
that's our show you guys tomorrow is our
last show of the week and then we are
off Monday I just wanted to remind
everyone because we respect bank
holidays here we will never let a bank
holiday pass without honoring it no we
kind of like are a bank I would say I
would say that too we're like a bank
yeah yeah so if you ever want to know
where we're at like check your local
bank see what they're doing yeah that's
what we're doing thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
everybody through Friday on YouTube so
if you're watching us on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so Spotify iTunes Stitch or public
radio I hear we do castbox all the
places wherever you listen to podcast
find us a totally five star review about
a beautiful stunning smart and wickedly
talented we are a Delta Zim hope you
guys have a great day and we'll see you
tomorrow for
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
goodbye love ya bye